the state of the union is strong but the
state of the state of the union is not
strong we'll Nancy Pelosi disinvite
President Trump will president Trump
show up anyway do we even need a State
of the Union speech we will analyze them
Democrat representative alon omar
implies that Lindsey Graham is gay Rudy
Giuliani implies the president Trump's
campaign may have colluded with the
Russians and a pro-life activist gets
punched in the face then the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
so much to get to and first some
breaking news it's coming in just in the
last hour or so big developments coming
through the Russia probe with regard to
how the DOJ and the FBI handled that
steel dossier it looks like a lot of
senior DOJ and FBI officials lied we're
getting this from then associate
attorney general Bruce ORS testimony
today before Congress we'll get to that
in a second but first let's make a
little money honey with Lending Club if
you are carrying revolving debt that
means that you're not paying off your
card every month and you could be paying
thousands in interest every year that
you don't have to with Lending Club you
can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club has
helped millions of people regain control
of their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans you don't need
to go to the bank you don't need high
interest credit cards this really
appeals to me as a millennial because I
never want to leave my couch just go to
Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days you
don't even need to deposit a check
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued
billion with ABI just go to Lending Club
dot-com / Knowles ko wles
check your rate in minutes and borrow up
to 40 G's that's Lending Club com /
Knolls KO wles
Lending Club com / Knolls KO wles all
loans made by webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender I really want to
get to the State of the Union today but
first we have to go over this breaking
news Bruce or you might have heard that
name with regard to the collusion
investigation the Russia probe Muller
it's one of these names that floats
around with Andrew McCabe and Peter
struck and Lisa page all of these names
with it what the Democrats are hoping
here is that you are so confused by
everything that's going on in the Russia
probe that you just can't put the pieces
together oh who is Bruce or again who is
this it was that so Bruce or was the
associate attorney general he was the
fourth ranking official in the entire
Department of Justice he just testified
before the house that the
Oh Jay knew about the steel dossier the
one that had all those lurid unverified
details about weird sex in Moscow that
they had that earlier than he then had
previously been testified now Bruce or
matters because Bruce or his wife Nellie
or was working for fusion GPS which was
an opposition research firm that put
together de stijl dossier that
contracted this guy Christopher Steele
to do the steel dossier this was bought
and paid for by the Clinton campaign and
the the DNC Bruce or the associate
attorney generals wife was working for
them and Bruce or did not publicly
disclose this this is just one of the
many things that smell really fishy
about this whole Russia investigation so
anyway Bruce or goes up to Congress he
testifies that the previous testimony
about when the FBI and DOJ knew about
that steel dossier was false previously
we had heard that the DOJ and the FBI
did not know about the steel dossier
until September and so this matters
because they then in October went to get
a FISA warrant to surveil Carter page
working for the Trump campaign okay now
what we find out from Bruce or who's in
a real position to know is that he told
the FBI and the DOJ about Christopher
steel about has steel was working for
the Democrats about how Christopher
steel quote was desperate that Trump not
be elected he told them about this in
July so now they know about this in July
they know that this dossier is not only
unverified but it's politically biased
it's bought and paid for by Democrats
and that the guy who put it together has
a serious grudge against Donald Trump
does not want him to be elected never
the less the FBI and the DOJ persist for
a few months then they go to get the the
FISA warrant in October and they
basically lie to the federal judge so
they are they at least mislead the
federal judge in October of 2016 to get
that FISA warrant and this is a big deal
you might say well lawyers mislead
judges all the time it's very different
in the FISA courts James Comey himself
testified about this he said on December
7th that this amounts to abuse of the
FISA system
it is totally expected that when the DOJ
and FBI go before the FISA judges they
will present all of the evidence not
just part of the evidence and say look
some intelligence person says that
Donald Trump made a weird videotape in
Moscow with a bunch of hookers on
Obama's dead
that it's not just that you present that
but you'll also say oh by the way this
has not been verified the guy who did it
it has a grudge against Donald Trump
he's desperate for him not to be elected
oh and by the way it was paid for by
Hillary Clinton and the Democrats if you
leave that part out you are misleading
the federal judge that's what Bruce or
fourth ranking DOJ official is alleging
now is testifying before the Congress
this is a game changer it's not a game
changer in that we already knew that
this Russia investigation stunk to high
heaven but now we're getting it from the
horse's mouth or at least the fourth
ranking horse's mouth a really really
big event I think probably what it means
is you're gonna see Muller turn up the
heat even more you're going to see
Democrats rally around Muller even more
but this whole investigation seems
illegitimate we got to talk about the
State of the Union because the State of
the Union is coming up or maybe it's not
I don't know if it's come maybe it's
coming up maybe it's not coming up there
is a debate now over whether Nancy
Pelosi will invite Donald Trump to give
the State of the Union because the State
of the Union is held at the Capitol so
the way that it works is the president
has his speech he writes up his
memorandum on the State of the Union and
he sends it to the Capitol and then the
Congress invites the president to come
give the address now the Congress is run
by Democrats so it's up to Nancy Pelosi
to invite him Nancy Pelosi is saying
that she won't do it because the
government is shut down and there could
be security concerns here is Nancy
Pelosi just during that commercial break
our team on Capitol Hill heard for the
first time from Speaker Nancy Pelosi
since she essentially uninvited the
president for the State of the Union on
January 29th here's what she had to say
about all of the resources that are
needed to to prepare for a State of the
Union address which he calls what a
special an advantage of special security
and and so these people are not working
and we've never really had a State of
the Union when government has been shut
down since the budget adopted in the 70s
so this is per this is respectfully and
sadly what proudly I invited him to come
the people horse that we would have the
President of the United States this
issue she goes on she talks about how
terrible Trump is but listen to the tax
she's taking she's not saying I am NOT
going to invite the president because
the government is shut down and I hate
his guts she's not doing that she's
trying to seem above it all and so
mature and what she is doing is blaming
the Secret Service in the Department of
Homeland Security she said she was proud
to invite the president to give the
address but you know the security it so
with the government shutdown how can we
possibly protect the president don't
forget the government has partially shut
down nothing has changed virtually all
government services are still running
but apparently Nancy Pelosi thinks we
can't protect the president during a
very minor partial shutdown that has not
affected virtually any other aspect of
the government this is pretty cynical
she put this in a letter to the
president which is not really a letter
to the president it's a letter to the
Washington Post she wrote this letter to
the president she immediately released
it to the press
I assume the president never even got it
and she said look the Secret Service and
homeland security they say and they just
can't do it that's a lie
that is a lie and it's not just a lie
that they because they can do it it's a
lie because they've said that they can
do it the the statement was released the
Secret Service and Department of
Homeland Security said they can handle
security a president from State of the
Union address this is from Secretary of
Homeland Security Kirsten Nielsen she
said quote the Department of Homeland
Security and the US Secret Service are
fully prepared to support and secure the
State of the Union we thanked the
service for their mission focus and
dedication for all that they do each day
to secure our home
and couldn't be more clear she's she
could not possibly be more clear about
this so it's a it's a sick play from
Nancy Pelosi and it's weak because he
could call her out on this I mean the
big question is she has invited him but
now has suggested they have to postpone
it because of security so if he comes
back and says well my Secretary of
Homeland Security said it's absolutely
fine so deal with it I'm coming what is
she gonna do is she gonna bar him from
coming in I don't think so I don't
really think that's gonna work and and
most presidents would abide by the rule
but I don't know Donald Trump probably
won't you know if any president is going
to go barge in like a conservative
speaker on a left-wing campus kick in
the doors and go give the speech it's
gonna be Donald Trump
so we'll see I mean we're getting the
reality TV show that we've all asked for
that's why I don't complain about it
this is what we wanted this is what the
president thrives on this is how he
accomplished as much of his agenda so
fine that's okay the question is should
we have a State of the Union address at
all conservatives raise this question
all the time the State of the Union
comes from one line in the Constitution
from article 2 section 3 it reads he
shall referring to the president from
time to time give to Congress
information of the State of the Union
and recommend to their consideration
such measures as he shall judge
necessary and expedient so I know a lot
of conservatives especially the more
libertarian minded conservatives they
hate the State of the Union
they think it's monarchical they think
it is too regal for America they read
that line and they say he should just
mail them a letter and say ok there's
information read it enjoy whatever you
want but the history of the State of the
Union is actually a little more regal
than that and it doesn't just go back
the last 50 years it actually goes back
all the way to George Washington we'll
get to it in a second but first let's
talk about purple mattress which I love
you can hear right now I'm sure you can
hear it my voice it's been raining in LA
for about seven years now and so my
allergies are just really really acting
up it's hard to sleep it's all this the
only thing that was giving me a good
night's sleep is my purple mattress
which I love and you know that I love it
purple is unlike any mattress you've
ever slept
it is not exactly memory foam it's not
an innerspring it is this proprietary
technology developed by a rocket
scientist it's super cool it is both
firm and soft at the same time what does
that mean I can't really tell you you
have to experience it yourself it sleeps
really cool unlike some other mattresses
where you just feel like it's trapping
all the heat it's just the best mattress
I've ever slept on I'm recommending it
to all of my friends I'm chipping in and
buying some for my friends I just love
it I'm proselytizing the thing you will
love it too
there's a hundred night risk-free trial
if you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
you won't return it it's backed by a ten
year warranty free shipping and returns
free in-home setup an old mattress
removal you will love it and right now
my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great gifts
they're offering site-wide how do you
get it just text cough fac OVF efe two
four seven four seven four seven that's
the only way to get this free pillow to
text cough fac OVF efe two four seven
four seven four seven CoV fe fe four
seven four seven four seven message and
data rates may apply it's a small price
to pay for the best sleep of your life
so these conservatives especially the
libertarian minded ones hate the State
of the Union they want to get rid of it
and they think it's it's just - it's too
British you know it's like the king
walking in in his robes and sitting on
the throne and that's anti-american and
that's terrible I have a little bit of a
different view on this because they they
they push it too much they take it too
much to an extreme the State of the
Union contrary to what they say is not
only a really a product of the 20th
century George Washington gave a State
of the Union address on January 8th 1790
he gave that one obviously not in the
White House which didn't exist yet but
in New York City and he delivered the
speech and he was a pretty regal guy and
people stood when he was in the room and
he was certainly no you know lower [ __ ]
and lowercase D Democrat populist or
anything like that there was a real
dignity to the office obviously a real
dignity to the man and a dignity to the
speech Thomas Jefferson scrapped the
practice in when
became president and this tells you all
you need to know because Thomas
Jefferson was much more of a lowercase D
Democrat he despised the idea of a
monarchy or anything Menorca coal in
America so he discontinued it and that
tradition held for over a hundred years
it held until Woodrow Wilson one of the
worst presidents in American history
in 1913 Wilson reestablished the
practice so now the real historical
record is a little more complex
Washington did it so I like that
Jefferson didn't do it which makes me
like the State of the Union even more
Wilson did it which makes me not like
the State of the Union
what are we to land on he gave the
speech it then continued throughout the
20th century I believe the last time we
skipped it was Jimmy Carter in 1981
Jimmy Carter was so bitter that he had
lost the election to Ronald Reagan that
he refused to give a State of the Union
address and he just sent the address to
Congress and they read it I will say
Antonin Scalia would not attend the
State of the Union he thought it was a
ridiculous farce and he despised that
the judges couldn't smile or move or do
anything while they were listening to
the executive branch he felt that it it
subordinated the judicial to the
executive I kind of liked it I kind of
liked the State of the Union in so much
as the office of the president is he's
not just a dog catcher he's not just a
guy at the DMV he's not just your county
executive there is a real dignity there
because he represents the spirit of the
nation the ethos of the nation he is the
executive and as the nation as the
greatest country in the history of the
world these super power on earth this
imbues the office with with a sense of
the regal it imbues the office with a
real dignity and a real gravity so I
kind of like it for that reason I think
it would be bizarre and incongruous if
the president you know just sent out a
tweet on the State of the Union
I guess if any president were gonna do
that it would be this president but he's
also a good showman as well and the
other reason I mean we've been talking
all week about these different strains
of conservative thought the grandeur
sort of concern
the traditionalist conservatives maybe
would prefer it a little bit more than
libertarians not so much but one thing
we should be able to agree on is even if
you hate the State of the Union this is
not the way to get rid of the State of
the Union this is the way to get rid of
it is not through a temper tantrum
because Nancy Pelosi doesn't like Donald
Trump that seems kind of wrong to me
you know the conservative tends to
prefer evolution to revolution we like
gradual things we don't like crazy
radical change all at once and this
would seem to be a really sad way for
the State of the Union a legacy of
George Washington to disappear from
American public life or to be skipped
over that seems wrong Nancy Pelosi
should grow up she's probably not gonna
grow up even though she's been called
out on the lies that are the basis for
her not having president Trump give the
State of the Union he should show up
anyway if she won't have him he should
show up anyway and just take over that
that chamber you know Donald Trump
apparently the White House is now asking
Mitch McConnell to see if the Senate
Majority Leader can invite the President
to give the State of the Union
traditionally it as the Speaker of the
House could the Senate Majority Leader
do it I don't know I don't know that
anybody really has an answer to that so
they're looking at that but in any case
Pelosi has invited him and he should
take her up on that invitation we've got
to get back to Russia briefly because
there was a bizarre exchange on Chris
Cuomo's show on CNN today there are
usually bizarre exchanges on Chris Cuomo
in the show this is not exactly a Man
Bites Dog story but Rudy Giuliani the
lawyer for the president seems to imply
that the Trump campaign may have
colluded with Russia and now I don't
think this is the bombshell story that
the mainstream media are making it out
to be but you've got to watch the clip
and decide for yourself between the
campaign or between people in the
campaign I have not I said the president
United States there is not a single bit
of evidence the present United States
committed the only crime you could admit
here conspired with the Russians to hack
the dnc first of all crime is not the
bar of accountability for a president
it's about what you knew leading was
right it was wrong and what did you
deceive about those are going to be
dangerous considerations the president
did not
nobody had any contact under concert
nobody colluded okay so the big headline
NBC New York Times is that Trump's
lawyer is unsure whether campaign
colluded with Russia now that I mean
this was not a great media appearance
for Rudy Giuliani but it's not as big a
story it seems because we already know
that virtually everybody on both sides
of this question colluded with the
Russians
whatever that means I mean first of all
define collusion what do we mean by
collusion the reason that the Democrats
glommed onto this term is because it's
so vague there's no crime of collusion
there's no impeachable offense of
collusion what does collusion mean
Dwight do I collude with my barista when
I go get a coffee in the morning do I
collude with Andrew Clavin regularly I
collude with Andrew Clavin does Ben
collude with gangsters to have me
assassinated on't no I'm just saying
what does collusion mean we know that
Paul Manafort colluded with the Russians
okay we know that not during the Trump
campaign maybe but we know that he's
worked with pro-russian forces in
Ukraine this was no secret he was a
lobbyist an international lobbyist a
very prominent one by the way we know
that Hillary Clinton's campaign
Chairman's brother Tony Podesta major
democrat lobbyist also colluded with the
Russians on the same campaign now we
know that the Democrats and Hillary
Clinton and the FBI and the DOJ colluded
with the Russians on the Russian
investigation how do we know that
because they went through fusion GPS
funded by the DNC and Hillary to
contract Christopher steel to get them
dirt on Donald Trump and Christopher
still got that dirt by talking to
Russian intelligence and people familiar
with Russian intelligence that's the
only way he could have gotten the dirt
all of the information the apparent
state-owned Kremlin owned Donald Trump
sex tape that would have had to come
from sources within Russian intelligence
so we actually know for a fact that all
of the Democrat forces plus the federal
government under Barack Obama colluded
with the Russians in a way much more
significant than Paul Manafort who was
briefly the chairman of the Trump
campaign doing some lobbying work for
the Russians
years ago the question is not about
collusion as Rudy Giuliani rightly
points out the question is was there a
crime committed and listen Chris Cuomo
gives away the whole story here he gives
away the whole game of the left he said
well the bar of accountability is not
crime for the president the bar of
accountability is not crime because what
Chris Cuomo wants to do is lower the bar
of accountability to ever having watched
a rocky and bullwinkle episode or to
ever have read a Russian novel and then
all of a sudden you can say see see he's
compromised by the Russians and they can
get him to be impeached or run him out
of office run him out of town on a rail
the bar of accountability here is crime
Cuomo is completely wrong and Giuliani
is right the bar of accountability is
not only crime it's high crimes and
misdemeanors not not misdemeanors
meaning you know minor offenses like we
discussed now high crimes we're talking
about high crimes and misdemeanors as
that phrase was understood to mean in
the drafting of the Constitution and the
ratification did President Trump commit
a crime that's what you've got to ask
yourself when you hear about Bruce or
Peter struck Lisa Paige Andy McCabe if
you've got Bruce or telling all of these
people you know that the Christopher
Steele dossier was funded by Democrats
there was this grudge and all of those
people didn't report this or kept it
quiet or wouldn't tell the FISA Court
Judge you hear all of these names all of
these questions what these timelines
these days is that ask yourself one
question what crime did Donald Trump
commit they're now trying to get him on
a campaign finance violation which is
minor it is nothing they couldn't even
get ex senator John what was it John
Roberts what was that guy's name the oak
now John Roberts is the Chief Justice of
the court gosh that guy was so
forgettable that he ran for president in
2008 and we don't even remember his name
anymore whatever someone can write at
him in the comments they couldn't even
get him on this question and so the
question is the crime what did he commit
a crime with Russian Intel
John Edwards that was his name he that's
confusing because this the psychic TV
guy is also named John Edwards I don't
know there a lot of look John is a very
common name but they couldn't they
couldn't get him what is the crime that
they're gonna get Donald Trump on if
Chris Cuomo can't give an answer to that
then it's all just huff and puff and
puff and a whole lot of hot air but they
can't actually nail down the question
we've also got to get to Lindsey Graham
because this was outrageous but first
and we got the mailbag coming up ben
shapiro
tomorrow we'll be taking his show on the
road to the March for Life in DC at 10
a.m. Eastern Ben will be live streaming
at the National Mall and 12th Street so
if you're planning to be at the March
head over and see him in person if you
are on facebook and youtube go over to
Daley wire.com it's ten bucks a month
100 dollars for an annual membership you
get me you get the under Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom you
get everything most importantly you get
the only vessel to drink during the
State of the Union when President Trump
slides in Kicks down the door of the
Congress disbands the Parliament like
charles ii goes in and gives his make
America great again again again again
speech of the State of the Union you're
gonna need this leftist ears tumbler to
collect all of those salty delicious
leftist yours go to daily wire comm
we'll be right back
ilan Omar who is that anti-semite
somali-american freshman congresswoman
from the Democrat Party she she's the
first to wear a hijab in Congress as the
mainstream media have gleefully reported
she is now implying that Lindsey Graham
is gay that the Republican senator from
South Carolina Lindsey Graham is a gay
guy this this insinuation from Democrats
has been around for a long time because
Graham has never been married and he
doesn't have any kids listen to her make
it and listen to her deny it you tweeted
we're gonna put this up on the screen
regarding Republican congressman Senator
Lindsey Graham I believe we have this
tweet saying they got him he is
compromised and there it is I wonder if
you'd explain what what you were talking
about there that this is this is sparked
a fair amount of criticism not just from
Republicans can you explain that comment
so over the last three years we have
seen many times where Senator Lindsey
Graham has told us how dangerous this
president could be if he was given the
opportunity to be in the White House and
all of the sudden he's made not only a
hundred and eighty turn around but a 360
turn around and so I am pretty sure that
there is something happening with him
whether it is you know something that
has to do with his funding when it comes
to running for office whether it has
something to do with the polling that
they might have in in his district or
whether it has to do with some sort of
leadership within the Senate he is
somehow compromised he is somehow
compromised she's implying that he's gay
notice she leaves out conspicuously
leaves out that it could be about his
personal life but it's the same line
we've heard over and over and over the
one point I want to make here though
that Ilan Omar is it turns out she's no
better at math Matt
then she is a political philosophy she
says that Lindsey Graham has made not
only a 180-degree turnaround in his
opinion of Donald Trump he's made a 360
degree turn around so just for those of
you who can visualize it this I'll just
hold up the leftist here's tumblr if I
turn the leftist years tumblr 180
degrees you see it's you can't you can't
read it anymore it's the opposite and
then if I turn it a full 360 degrees
it's exactly the same if Lindsey Graham
in a 360 degree turn
that would mean he's saying the same
things today that he was saying two
years ago so maybe maybe when Ilan Omar
educates herself on history and
political philosophy and civics maybe
she could educate herself on mathematics
as well that might serve our country
while she's serving in the legislature
but she's clearly implying that he's gay
and now she's denying it in this very
coy way so no I'm just saying he's
compromised I don't know maybe it's
about what he had for breakfast maybe
he's not proud of eating pop-tarts for I
don't know or a that he's a gay guy and
the way you know this is they've been
doing it for years here's Stephanie
ruhle on MSNBC making the exact same
insinuation got elected Lindsey Graham
called Donald Trump a racist xenophobic
bigot that is Lindsey Graham's words I
doubt Lindsey Graham could tell you
Donald Trump's had a change of heart in
the last 24 months I bet what the change
of heart has been with Lindsey Graham
not the president or it could be that
Donald Trump or somebody knows something
pretty extreme about Lindsey Graham
something pretty extreme she says we're
gonna leave it there we're gonna pretty
extreme and this raises it so they
aren't they're implying that he's gay
and they've done it for a long time this
does raise an interesting point though
the left tells us that it's not only
okay to be gay it is great to be gay it
is so much better to be gay than to be
straight it makes you a part of a victim
group that then gives you certain
advantages and puts you in a more
important place in the intersectional
hierarchy of victimhood and that's
wonderful and it's diversity and that's
great except when a Republican is gay
they hate gay Republicans they do this
all the time they say they they love
racial minorities they love black people
and they hate
black Republicans they love women they
say women are so much better than men
but they hate women Republicans they
treat them all like dirt
they treat Tim Scott like dirt look at
what how they treated Clarence Thomas
just on the question of race look at
those two guys on the question of sexual
orientation they're gay shaming Lindsey
Graham who isn't gay we have no evidence
that he's gay he said he's always asked
this question he says look and as much
as it matters I'm not gay but basically
you screw you for asking and it's true
who cares who cares what his attraction
is it I don't know maybe he likes girls
maybe he likes boys he said he dated a
growing was younger he never got married
I don't know sex is complicated
sometimes people don't want to get
married especially if you're a prominent
politician okay
whatever the point is they're gay
shaming Lindsey Graham even though he's
not necessarily gay or there's no
evidence that he is same thing with
Sarah Palin same thing with nikki Haley
they talked about how Republicans must
hate women because we find Elizabeth
Warren unlikable we have plenty of women
who we promote or UN Ambassador nikki
Haley former governor of South Carolina
our vice presidential nominee Sarah
Palin how did the left treat those women
how what awful things did they say about
those women what awful things did they
say about hope Hicks in the White House
they were implying that she was sleeping
with the president what awful things do
they say about Kelly and Conway they
make fun of Sarah Sanders as looks it's
just a lie and I bring it up not to
focus on Elon Oh more Omar any more than
we have to or Lindsey Graham or any of
these other people but just to show you
the left doesn't care about racial
minorities or sexual minorities or women
or they don't care at all they use them
like tools they turn them into tools so
use them as a cudgel to beat up the
right and before we get to the mailbag I
do also have to point out just a little
bit of good news today the Senate has
rebuked Kamala Harris and mazie Hirono
to Democrat senators and Kamala Harris
is running for president the Senate
posted this out today over they voted on
this rather and then they posted it to
the Internet where we could all read it
the sense of the Senate that
disqualifying a nominee to federal
office on the basis of membership in the
Knights of Columbus violates the Khan
- Sh enough the United States that
that's a terrible thing it's a terrible
thing to violate someone's freedom of
religion and to try to disqualify a
judicial nominee the reason that they're
rebuking these two women Kamala Harrison
mazie Hirono is they raise the question
over whether a judicial nominee whose
name was Brian Buescher whether his
membership in a Catholic organization
disqualified him from being judge this
isn't the first time this has happened
dianne feinstein put it in absurdly
stark terms talking about a female
catholic judicial nominee lives loudly
within you and that's of concern the
dogma lives loudly within you they do
this to Karen pence Karen pence the vice
president president's wife is working in
a Christian school which holds two
Christian moral and sexual teaching and
they're so upset about this they're
furious how awful the Democrats have a
religion problem here they don't take
religion seriously and so because they
don't take religion seriously they fall
into their own ideological religion
completely unawares they don't realize
there's any alternative to progressivism
which is their religion the trouble is
everybody's got to serve somebody as
many people have observed at bottom all
political problems are theological and
Democrats blindness on this issue
totaled not just ignorant not not just
kooky ideas but actual blindness on the
issue is I think part of the reason why
they are so dysfunctional in our
politics at the moment we can get to all
of this in the mailbag I am determined
to get through a lot of questions so
let's start it right now from Parker hi
Michael where do you stand on the moral
trolley dilemma where five people will
be killed by a runaway trolley but you
can push one person presumably innocent
in its path to save them
do you believe saving five lives
outweighs the one you'll harm or do you
believe any involvement is morally
objectionable does the answer to this
lie within the Bible yes there is a an
answer to this coming really from Thomas
Aquinas you've I think misstated the
problem a little bit the trolley problem
is this question of you're there you've
got
lever to which way the trolley is going
to go on one side there are five people
tied to the tracks on the other side
there's one person tied to the tracks
the train is traveling at the five
people and you can pull the lever and
have it turn toward the one person is
this permitted this is permitted what
would you do it's really up to you this
relies on the principle of double effect
there are four criteria for the
principle of double effect one is that
the action done should be intrinsically
good or morally neutral regarding
pulling the lever to the bad act must
not be the means by which one achieves
the good act so it cannot be the case
that the people are saved because of
killing the one guy now killing the one
guy might be an effect of saving the
five people but it can't be the case
that the five people are killed because
you kill the one guy number three you
intend the good effect and you do not
intend the bad effect either as a means
to the good or as an end in itself
obviously and the bad effect must not be
disproportionate to the good effect so
if in the trolley question you have a
choice it would be morally permissible
to pull the lever and have the train
derailed and kill the one guy and not
kill the five people or to do nothing
would also be morally permissible
because you're in a you're dealing with
a question of double effect it's funny
how this this question was answered with
great of great effect by Thomas Aquinas
you know a very very long time ago and
yet people still discuss it as though
there's no answer to the question there
is clearly an answer and we all know in
our gut that probably either one is fine
or maybe we'd be more likely to pull it
and go for the one guy but the answer is
not quite so clear as we always want it
to be as we want to form some ideology
and a checklist and say this is what we
do but the reasoning the moral reasoning
that gets you to that answer I think is
is much more interesting and has a far
greater effect on real problems you will
encounter assuming you don't find
yourself on the train tracks with many
people tied to the rails
Samuel hi Michael is that the famed
Shapiro check that sits framed on the
fireplace in your studio best Sam so
it's funny you ask that Sam there it is
here is one of my most prized
possessions the check that I received
from Ben Shapiro for accurately
predicting that Donald Trump would win
the 2016 presidential election he gave
me four to one odds so I only bet a
hundred bucks he gave me four hundred
bucks and there in the memo line you can
read it says for ignoring data I do love
it and I framed it but just to be clear
I did mobile deposit the check first so
I certainly took the money and who would
not just leave it sitting there in class
from Patrick if you had to pick a
candidate to win primary in general in
2020 out of the announced and probable
Democrat field for president which would
you prefer
thanks PJ I'd like Liz Warren to win the
primary she's the most beatable
candidate for the general election so I
want her to win the primary if it had to
be someone who would win the primary and
the general meaning we would have to
live with a Democrat president that's
really hard of the announced candidates
they're all so far left-wing I suppose
Joe Biden is probably the most moderate
of the possible nominees he hasn't quite
announced yet but it certainly looks
like he's going to run so I guess if I
had to deal with someone you know if I
had to choose between arsenic and
cyanide I guess I would go with Joe
Biden but they're all pretty terrible
that party has shifted far to the left
and any person who wins the Democrat
primary in 2020 is going to so have to
shift to the left that they'll probably
be indistinguishable by the time the
general rolls around so sad from Mike hi
Michael my name is also Michael so you
should answer my question okay how did
the Democrat Party become the mainstream
party could the Republican Party ever
become the mainstream party and would
that even be a good thing thanks Michael
you have been so brainwashed Michael by
our pop culture that you don't realize
that the Republicans are the mainstream
I don't mean this to attack you or
anything like that
but Republicans until about a week ago
or two weeks
ago held all three branches of
government and basically had the Supreme
Court and had spent the previous ten
years or eight years taking over every
state house in the country Republicans
are the mainstream party now it doesn't
seem that way because you're spending
time in high school or college or in
corporate America or wherever and you're
watching the popular culture in the
movies and listening to the music and
watching TV news but just look at the
effect the mainstream has been the
Republican party we we have the
presidency we still have two of the
three houses of government to use
Alexandria cassio cortezes incorrect
phrasing we still have the Senate and we
still have the presidency and the
Democrats just retook the house so we
are mainstream the question is how will
we retake the culture that's going to be
much harder because conservatives don't
care that much about the culture the
left does because they play a longer
game and the left cares more about
politics so they're willing to go
further for it I hope that we can do it
some people are trying to retake the
culture drew writes movies I perform in
his audio books and film projects and
things like that
but unfortunately it's going to take a
much more concerted effort at the
universities and at the movie studios
and at the publishing houses rather than
just focusing on think tanks and
politicians from our unum dear dr. Co
FFA speaking of doctors what do you
think about PhDs asking to be referred
to as doctor thanks love the show a PhDs
are the only real doctors why is a
medical doctor referred to as doctor why
is a physician referred to as doctor
doctor comes from the Latin word doctor
or doc RA which means to teach doctor
means teacher so when you're a teacher
you're a doctor so a PhD in art history
or something it makes sense for that
person to be a doctor but a physician is
not a doctor they're a physician or a
surgeon they wear a stethoscope you know
the word doctor doesn't mean wears a
stethoscope so for those of us you know
who have wives for instance who are
working on PhDs right now I suppose that
when those wives get the PhD then we
will be some of the only people whose
wife's are doctors from Nicholas Hema
just wondering what you think about
niccolò machiavelli
and the prince hashtag came for been
stayed for Knowles it's nice I signed
another one actually someone said I saw
a hashtag came for been stayed for been
but I also watched Knowles now which
I'll take I'll take what I can get
I love reading Machiavelli I actually
did a translation the first English
stage translation of Machiavelli's first
play and a lot of people don't realize
that niccolò machiavelli who wrote the
prince kind of invented modern political
science and in some ways maybe invented
the modern political era he was also a
playwright and a translator of plays so
I did a translation of his first play
the girl from Andros I loved reading him
I think he's one of the most
consequential thinkers in the history of
the world however he's the guy who
invented modernity and I don't care that
much for modernity so I much prefer the
the actual content of other political
thinkers but he's truly a great genius
and one thing about monkey of Elie also
like Edmund Burke is that he wasn't just
a political theorist he actually was a
practitioner he held offices he was a
diplomat he he was really in the reality
of politics and politics as a practical
science so he knew what he was talking
about I have time for one more from
Brendan what is the best book for a
college conservative to read well you
know my answer really fast I know you're
busy in college the fastest most
important read it would be reasons to
vote for Democrats a comprehensive guide
by Michael J Knowles
but after that I would recommend that
you read the conservative mind by
Russell Kirk there were too many good
books to recommend reflections on the
revolution in France God and man at Yale
up from liberalism also by Buckley is a
good one witnessed by Whittaker Chambers
is fabulous there's there's so many to
read obviously Aristotle and Plato and
the Bible blah blah blah goes on and on
read the conservative mind I think
that's a it's good for a college aged
student specifically for conservatives
specifically for American conservatives
I think you'll enjoy it okay that's our
show I hope you have a good weekend in
the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Doyle show I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case production
assistant Nick shyam hair and makeup is
by Jessa all Vera the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19